the holiday weekend could set new travel
records triple-a estimates more than 44
million people will travel at least 50
miles from home that includes me that
would be the busiest Independence Day
weekend ever CBS News travel editor
Peter Greenberg is here good morning
good morning let's talk first about the
airports what should people expect
slower times because as they phase in
the new security rules be prepared
they'll be secondary screening meaning
not just the primary screening where you
go through the conveyor belt with your
laptop or any of your carry-on items but
there may be secretary screaming at the
gates where they're going to actually
ask you to take out your computer again
maybe and turn it on so we know that
they're looking at the passengers I've
often wondered about the people behind
the scenes who are loading on the
baggage we're putting on the food that's
part of what the DHS is saying is the
unseen security they're going to start
vetting more and more of the catering
workers the guys who are driving the
trucks the rampers even as far back as
the catering facility before they even
get to the airport because once they
lock up those catering trucks it just
goes right to the plane and Peter those
applies domestically as well as
internationally absolutely as a
practical matter as in fact all those
airlines that were affected by the
laptop band can get out of that band
right now by performing these sorts of
screening services gas prices haven't
been this low since 2005 how does that
affect travel about three percent more
people going to be traveling this year
37 point five million people be on the
road you too and that's great I mean
when you deal with the gas prices that
are hovering around $2 a gallon that's a
great deal
so yes more people on the road but keep
in mind Gallup reports 47% of US adults
are less likely to want to travel
overseas right now so as a result you
have a global buyers market in travel
meaning you have foreign airlines
increasing their capacity at 61% never
at this time of the year
so coach air fares right now down 23
percent over last year and International
Affairs ridiculous friend of mine went
to Ireland last week for Los Angeles
what do you think the round-trip fare
was $300 $130 Wow Wow so law supply and
demand now's the time if you want to do
it I'm just glad to know you are friends
thank you very much should I give up my
number
thank you Peter always good to thank you
girl thank you very much